nationwide building society is a very
very large financial institution in the
uk what do i mean well here we go
nationwide building society it's a
british mutual financial institution
it's the seventh largest cooperative
financial institution and the largest
building society in the world they have
over 15 million members they do 4.5
billion dollars in revenue they were
founded in 1846 they have over 18 000
employees and total assets are 350
billion dollars now why the hell am i
talking about nationwide building
society well nationwide building
society's entire payment system went
down yesterday that's right
one of the largest organizations that
employs over 18 000 people they got 15
million customers they have 350 billion
dollars in assets
they literally can't keep their service
up we're sorry there's a delay affecting
some payments to and from your account
this morning we're gonna fix it asap
your direct debits and standing orders
are unaffected and working normally
ashley well the system went down it's
the third time that the bank servers
have failed since christmas eve and so
ultimately when we start to look at this
you can see that their business is not
working if you're a financial
institution and you can't allow for
payments and the payment rails to work
now of course this is just like a
softball for me to say nationwide
payment systems are down bitcoin was up
bitcoin is always up bitcoin doesn't
have hours of operations bitcoin doesn't
get hacked bitcoin doesn't shut down
bitcoin doesn't have its servers all of
a sudden become malfunctioning bitcoin
is always working and so while it's on a
small scale it's an outlier it's a small
small example
nationwide going down yesterday shows
that there is centralized risk if you
count on them either for a savings
account for your debits for your
payments for your mortgage etc you
couldn't participate in the financial
system yesterday because they were down
they couldn't keep the service up now
they don't do that every day but do you
want to operate in a financial system
100 of your financial life where you
don't know whether it's going to stay up
or not of course not and that's why
bitcoin ends up being so interesting
it's always up it's always on you have
always have access to your money you can
transact with whoever you want whenever
you want without asking permission of
anyone doesn't matter with the suits and
ties with the cologne and the slicked
back hair nationwide do i'm sure they're
great people but they couldn't keep the
service up yesterday and so there's
millions of people who are affected
but there's also millions of people
using bitcoin
and you ain't stopping them